[Music]
[Music]
as soon as so those plants started to
shut down we have to slow down because
of illnesses of workers in those plants
we weren't able to produce as much meat
as we're accustomed to we're down about
40 percent of our processing compared to
the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
IQ below to chose another Yahoo Lopez or
a minor contributor to the sea
and it 21 people that are doing a song
see you want to take this money so I can
go KBO I go to Pune she Manzo terumah
Kingdom buzzer you did she wore for
those who don't know where she's a cross
between Martha Stewart and Kim
Kardashian we're here today at the front
of the dome from oil factory where Waya
will host an hours-long fundraiser for
Han struggling businesses back on April
1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars Sami the season 40
million people in China are watching is
lodged in the show I seen herself and
taste very thing from [ __ ] actor
crayfish life is slowly returning back
to Mohan right across the street from
the fawn on seafood market we were told
by the police not to take any photos in
front of the market we heard today that
a lot of the sellers will
[Music]
[Music]
now what you put in teams are FIFA were
contacted by physicians who alerted us
to the importance of being able to use
this device potentially to measure
clapping and respiratory activity and
also temperature from this region of the
body
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I ran medicine are you professional de
los Estados Unidos I declare a doe por
el miembro de la seguridad de Donald
Trump e el Senor look alexander Denman
igualmente member olace agora they
Donald was also there may have
accumulated singularity a case on their
offensive we are a towel
[Music]
whatever it is well let you know but
there's nothing to do with our
[Music]
government racha racha racha racha dog
my identity camuto please tell them okay
Pushkin America Coliseum with a robot
boy Felicitas own characters attending a
tomato soup Okinawa parade eventual
Super Nintendo porque si Chivas and
pathology Juventus on para Aaron SSTP
occitane you know mythology intelligence
of the DVD homage Trisha for magic Juan
de la familia man which is a subject
team owner Ramesh follow your physical
pooja my sage Tremaine - you know boss
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have become
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now the spacecraft you know
once we launch it and it's out in space
if something goes wrong you know nobody
can go up there and fix that that one
little thing and so in that regard we're
used to happy to you know very very
meticulously analyze any potential fault
scenario that we could encounter for us
ace craft and for a medical device you
know we we took that same exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next-level
make a lot of us really don't know how
it's gonna be to adjust they're going
back to just working on spacecraft yeah
it's a really interesting paradigm shift
I'm sure a lot of orders just kid taking
like instantly in less than 10 seconds
you got to be quick instead of me just
being stuck inside the house and be able
to do something productive and make
money while doing it
signed up around wink Ovid really
started going people would just be
ordering things around out of stock
[Music]
I'll go to an area that I think is
pretty busy or I know is pretty busy
from past experience and I just sit
there on the app and just refresh it
about two to three days a week the insta
guard game is pretty competitive
sometimes I'll work really hard a huge
order and I'll be kind of upset that you
know just just not getting any tips
getting the little fee that's it that's
their charge from instacart wearing a
face mask at all times
I keep hand sanitizer on me I also
sanitize my car cuz I'm always reading
stuff inside my car as well
I did strike gold on one big order got
about a $500 order it's not always like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh Charles international magazine Shiva
Camuto three tender pork a yushkin
America Coliseum with a robot political
some characters attending a lot of
animosity towards Allah Allah Allah
porque no to apparel giving soprano
antenna porque si tu vas a Sanford
religion Juventus on para la necesidad
de uma mythology meteorology sobrevivir
homage Trisha for magic Juan de la
familia neck which is a subliminal image
follow your physical pooja my sage
remain to you know pass
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have become
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now the spacecraft you know
once we launch it and it's out in space
if something goes wrong you know nobody
can go up there and fix that that one
little thing and so in that regard we're
used to having to you know very very
meticulously analyze any potential fault
scenario that we can encounter for us
ace craft and for a medical device you
know we we took that same exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next level I think
a lot of us really don't know how it's
gonna be to adjust it going back to just
working on spacecraft yeah it's a really
interesting paradigm shift for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe your purpose on this planet
is enormous planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as so those plants started to
shut down we have to slow down because
of illnesses of workers in those plants
we weren't able to produce as much meat
as we're accustomed to we're down about
40 percent of our processing compared to
the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've Q little charcoal another Yahoo
look this'll remind okay hundred other
to the co-owner students each other
20,000 people that are doing a song see
you but she I don't wonder need to take
this money
- well choi hyung-woo kbo i would open a
freshman's o-tama
kingdom buzzer you did she go for those
who don't know where she's a cross
between Martha Stewart and Kim
Kardashian we're here today at the front
of the dome from oil factory where Waya
will host an hours-long fundraiser for
Han struggling businesses back on April
1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars 40 million people in
China are watching his live stream to
show I see herself and taste everything
from duck neck to crayfish life is
slowly returning back to normal high
right across the street from the phonon
seafood market we were told by the
police not detecting father
we might see a woman shouldn't tease our
beef up a lot of orders just kid taking
like instantly in less than 10 seconds
you got to be quick instead of me just
being stuck inside the house and be able
to do something productive and make
money while doing it
signed up around went Ovid really
started going people would just be
ordering things around out of stock
[Music]
I'll go to an area that I think is
pretty busy or I know is pretty busy
from past experience and I just sit
there on the app and just refresh it
about two to three days a week
the insta gar game is pretty competitive
sometimes I'll work really hard on huge
order and I'll be kind of upset that you
know just just not getting any tips in
the little fee that's it that they're
charged from instacart
wearing a face mask at all times I keep
hand sanitizer on me I also sanitize my
car because I'm always bringing stuff
inside my car as well
I did strike gold on one big order got
about a $500 order it's not always like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
et cetera
okay Philippi Church Aras international
magazine Shiva Camuto preach today okay
a Bushman and Ibaka resume with a robot
boy Felicitas own characters attending a
lot of animosity towards allah allah
allah so porque no to apparel
Givenchy Allah so prayer antenna porque
si tu vas a ser para Eugene Juventus on
para allá necesita acts of day you know
me dodgy intelligence of the homage
Trisha for much colder for a familiar
name it is a subliminal image follow a
physical pooja my sage through mental
you know pass
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have become
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now with the spacecraft you
know once we launch it and it's out in
space if something goes wrong you know
nobody can go up there and fix that that
one little thing and so in that regard
we're used to happy to you know very
very meticulously analyze any potential
fall scenario that we could encounter
for us 8th craft and for a medical
device you know we we took that same
exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next-level make a
lot of us really don't know how it's
going to be to adjust to going back to
just working on spacecraft yeah it's a
really interesting paradigm shift for
sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe your purpose on this planet
on this planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as some of those plants started
to shut down we have to slow down
because of illnesses of workers in those
plants we were able to produce as much
meat as we're accustomed to we're down
about 40 percent of our processing
compared to the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ocular to chose another Yahoo look this
or America hundred other to receive Oh
20 thinkin people that are doing a song
see you wanna see that we need to see I
don't want to take this money - we're
sorry tengo que vio algo para shimazo
tehama
hinden buzzer you did she go for those
who don't know where she's a cross
between Martha Stewart and Kim
Kardashian we're here today at the front
of the tongue from oil factory where
Waya will host an hours-long fundraiser
for Han struggling businesses back on
April 1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars 40 million people in
China are watching his life's in the
show I seen herself encased breathing
from duck neck to crayfish life is
slowly returning back to normal behind
right across the street from the pond on
seafood market we were told by the
police not to take any photos in front
of the market and we've heard today that
allow the sellers will
I might know what would you put in teens
are deeper a lot of orders just kid
taking like instantly in less than 10
seconds he ought to be quick instead of
me just being stuck inside the house and
be able to do something productive and
make money while doing it
signed up around wink Ovid really
started going people would just be
ordering things around out of stock
[Music]
I'll go to an area that I think is
pretty busy or I know is pretty busy
from past experience and I'll just sit
there on the app and just refresh it
about two to three days a week
the in cigar game is pretty competitive
sometimes I'll work really hard a huge
order and I'll be kind of upset that you
know just just not getting any tips in
the little fee that's it that they're
charged from instacart wearing a face
mask at all times
I keep hand sanitizer on me I also
sanitize my car cuz I'm always reading
stuff inside my car as well
I did strike gold on one big order got
about a $500 order it's not always like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh Charles international magazine Shiva
Camuto preach tender pork a Bushman
America Coliseum with a robot
hi Bella citizen quwata illa Allah
Muhammad also me Cobra el de ballet
porque no chopper a Givenchy soprano
antenna porque si services am Polynesian
Juventus on para la necesidad so Tanguma
me dodgy intelligence of the video
homage Trisha for marijuana
paraphernalia neck which is a subliminal
image below a physical pooja my sage
remain to you know pass
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have become
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now the spacecraft you know
once we launch it and it's out in space
if something goes wrong you know nobody
can go up there and fix that that one
little thing and so in that regard we're
used to having to you know very very
meticulously analyze any potential fault
scenario that we could encounter for us
ace craft and for a medical device you
know we we took that same exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next level a lot
of us really don't know how it's going
to be to adjust it going back to just
working on spacecraft yeah it's a really
interesting paradigm shift for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe your purpose on this planet
this planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as some of those plants started
to shut down we have to slow down
because of illnesses of workers in those
plants we were able to produce as much
meat as we're accustomed to we're down
about 40 percent of our processing
compared to the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You Little Joe's another Yahoo
Local America's hundred other to receive
whoa
hello 22nd people that are doing a song
see you I don't want to take this money
sorry sorry tengo que vio algo de palma
she Manzo two minima
human buzzer you did she go to the
Guinea but for those who don't know
where she's a cross between Martha
Stewart and Kim Kardashian we're here
today at the front of the dome from oil
factory where Waya
will host an hours-long fundraiser for
Han struggling businesses back on April
1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars 14 million people in
China are watching his life's in the
show I see herself and tastes breathing
from sucking up to crayfish life is
slowly returning back to Momo behind
right across the street from the phonon
seafood market we were told by the
police not to take any photos in front
of the market and we heard today that a
lot of the sellers will be
I might know what would you put in teens
are beefed up a lot of orders just kid
taking like instantly in less than 10
seconds you got to be quick instead of
me just being stuck inside the house and
be able to do something productive and
make money while doing it
signed up around went Ovid really
started going people would just be
ordering things around out of stock
[Music]
I'll go to an area that I think is
pretty busy or I know is pretty busy
from past experience and I'll just sit
there on the app and just refresh it
about two to three days a week
the insta gar game is pretty competitive
sometimes I'll work really hard a huge
order and I'll be kind of upset that you
know just just not getting any tips
getting the little fee that that they're
charged from instacart
wearing a face mask at all times I keep
hand sanitizer on me I also sanitize my
car because I'm always bringing stuff
inside my car as well
I did strike gold on one big order got
about a $500 order it's not always like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Charles international magazine Shiva
Camuto Sando okay Pushkin America
Coliseum with a robot popular citizen
characters attending Allah Allah Allah
Allah Allah porque no to apparel giving
soprano antenna porque si tu vas a
Sanford religion Juventus on para la
necesidad so Tanguma made on a Nintendo
Hachiya sobrevivir homage Trisha for you
meant juan de la familia name which is a
subliminal image follow your physical
Pooja my sage remain to you know pass
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have become
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now the spacecraft you know
once we launch it and it's out in space
if something goes wrong you know nobody
can go up there and fix that that one
little thing and so in that regard we're
used to having to you know very very
meticulously analyze any potential fall
scenario that we could encounter for us
ace craft and for a medical device you
know we we took that same exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next level I think
a lot of us really don't know how it's
gonna be to adjust going back to just
working on spacecraft yeah it's a really
interesting paradigm shift for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe your purpose on this planet
his planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as so those plants started to
shut down we have to slow down because
of illnesses of workers in those plants
we weren't able to produce as much meat
as we're accustomed to we're down about
40 percent of our processing compared to
the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
archeology toss another Yahoo look
there's aa minor contributor to the CEO
whatever
20 thinkin people that are doing a song
see you wanna be alimony to take this
money so he can go KBO I would happily
Mishima's o-tama
him noon buzzer you did she go for those
who don't know where she's a cross
between Martha Stewart and Kim
Kardashian we're here today at the front
of the dome from oil factory where Waya
will host an hours-long fundraiser for
Han struggling businesses back on April
1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars 40 million people in
China are watching his life's in the
show I see herself and taste anything
from duck neck to crayfish life is
slowly returning back to normal behind
right across the street from the fawn on
seafood walkers we were told by the
police not detecting you photo
we allow the sellers to my god shouldn t
is our thief up a lot of orders just kid
taking like instantly in less than 10
seconds he ought to be quick
instead of me just being stuck inside
the house and be able to do something
productive and make money while doing it
signed up around went Ovid really
started going people would just be
ordering things around out of stock
[Music]
I'll go to an area that I think is
pretty busy or I know is pretty busy
from past experience and I just sit
there on the app and just refresh it
about two to three days a week
the in cigar game is pretty competitive
sometimes I'll work really hard on huge
order and I'll be kind of upset that you
know just just not getting any tips in
the little fee that they're charged from
instacart
wearing a face mask at all times
I keep hand sanitizer on me I also
sanitize my car because I'm always
reading stuff inside my car as well
I did strike gold on one big order got
about a $500 order it's not always like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Chanchala international magazine Shiva
Camuto fish tender pork a yushkin an
abomination with a robot web illogical
some characters attending a lot even Oh
merci beaucoup de la Falaise porque no
Chiappa rain
Givenchy soprano antenna porque si tu
vas a sample region Juventus on para la
necesidad so Tanguma
me dodgy intelligence of the David Oman
Trisha for you marijuana paraphernalia
neck which is a subliminal image follow
your physical Pooja
my sage remain to you know pass
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have become
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now the spacecraft you know
once we launch it and it's out in space
if something goes wrong you know nobody
can go up there and fix that that one
little thing and so in that regard we're
used to having to you know very very
meticulously analyze any potential fall
scenario that we could encounter for us
faith craft and for a medical device you
know we we took that same exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next level I think
a lot of us really don't know how it's
gonna be to adjust to going back to just
working on spacecraft yeah it's a really
interesting paradigm shift for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe your purpose on this planet
his planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as so those plants started to
shut down we have to slow down because
of illnesses of workers in those plants
we were able to produce as much meat as
we're accustomed to we're down about 40
percent of our processing compared to
the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i qo to toss another Yahoo Lopez on a
minor contributor to receive
and it 21 people that are doing a song
see you Monday to take this money
so I can go KBO I go to Pune she Manzo
terumah
Kingdom buzzer you did she wore for
those who don't know where she's a cross
between Martha Stewart and Kim
Kardashian we're here today at the front
of the dome from oil factory where Waya
will host an hours-long fundraiser for
Han struggling businesses back on April
1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars Sami the season 40
million people in China are watching his
largest in the show I see herself and
taste very thing from [ __ ] actor
crayfish life is slowly returning back
to Mohan right across the street from
the fawn on seafood market we were told
by the police not to take any photos in
front of the market we heard today that
a lot of the sellers will
[Music]
[Music]
my god woman shouldn't tease out do you
[ __ ] a lot of orders just kid taking
like instantly in less than 10 seconds
she ought to be quick instead of me just
being stuck inside the house and be able
to do something productive and make
money while doing it signed up around
Wachovia really started going people
would just be ordering things around out
of stock
[Music]
I'll go to an area that I think is
pretty busy or I know is pretty busy
from past experience and I just sit
there on the app and just refresh it
about two to three days a week the insta
guard game is pretty competitive
sometimes I'll work really hard in a
huge order and I'll be kind of upset
that you know just just not getting any
tips in the little fee that's it that
they're charged from instacart wearing a
face mask at all times
I keep hand sanitizer on me I also
sanitize my car cuz I'm always reading
stuff inside my car as well
I did strike gold on one big order got
about a $500 order it's not always like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Yashiro okay Philippi Church a large
international magazine Shiva Camuto fish
deli
okay your Bushman a Mirabeau from a film
with a robot boy Felicitas own
characterization actual parade eventual
Super Nintendo porque si si versus
oncology Juventus on parallel and SSP
acts of the you know mythology
intelligence of the devil homage Tricia
for much colder for a familiar name it
is a subliminal image follow a physical
Pooja
my sage through mental you know pass
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have come
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now the spacecraft you know
once we launch it and it's out in space
if something goes wrong you know nobody
can go up there and fix that that one
little thing and so in that regard we're
used to having to you know very very
meticulously analyze any potential fault
scenario that we can encounter for us
ace craft and for a medical device you
know we we took that same exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next level I think
a lot of us really don't know how it's
gonna be to adjust going back to just
working on spacecraft yeah it's a really
interesting paradigm shift for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe your purpose on this planet
his planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as some of those plants started
to shut down we have to slow down
because of illnesses of workers in those
plants we were able to produce as much
meat as we're accustomed to we're down
about 40 percent of our processing
compared to the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
archaeology chose another Yahoo Lopez on
a minor contributor to the sea
20 second people that are doing a song
see you I don't want to take this money
square so he hung okay boy I would open
Mishima's o-tama
hymnal buzzer he did she go for those
who don't know where she's a cross
between Martha Stewart and Kim
Kardashian we're here today at the front
of the dome from oil factory where Waya
will host an hours-long fundraiser for
Han struggling businesses back on April
1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars 40 million people in
China are watching his life's in the
show I see herself and taste everything
from duck neck to crayfish life is
slowly returning back to normal behind
right across the street from the phonon
seafood market we were told by the
police not to take any photos in front
of the market and we've heard today that
allow the sellers will be
to my to my job no woman should put in
teens are FIFA a lot of orders just kid
taking like instantly in less than 10
seconds you got to be quick instead of
me just being stuck inside the house and
be able to do something productive and
make money while doing it
signed up around wink Ovid really
started going people would just be
ordering things around out of stock I'll
go to an area that I think is pretty
busy or I know is pretty busy from past
experience and I just sit there on the
app and just refresh it about two to
three days a week the insta guard game
is pretty competitive sometimes I'll
work really hard in a huge order and
I'll be kind of upset that you know just
just not getting any tips in the little
fee that that they're charged from
instacart
wearing a face mask at all times I keep
hand sanitizer on me I also sanitize my
car because I'm always bringing stuff
inside my car as well
I did strike gold on one big order got
about a $500 order it's not always like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh Charles international magazine Shiva
Camuto fish tender pork a Pushkin
America Colosseum with a robot web
illogical some characters attending a
lot of animosity towards Allah Allah
Allah porque no Chiappa rain eventually
so prayer antenna porque si tu vas a
Sanford religion Juventus on para la
necesidad so Tanguma made on a Nintendo
Hachiya sobrevivir homage Trisha for you
meant juan de la familia name which is a
subliminal image follow your physical
fuji my sage remains to you know pass
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have become
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now the spacecraft you know
once we launch it and it's out in space
if something goes wrong you know nobody
can go up there and fix that that one
little thing and so in that regard we're
used to having to you know very very
meticulously analyze any potential fault
scenario that we could encounter for us
viii craft and for a medical device you
know we we took that same exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next level I think
a lot of us really don't know how it's
gonna be to adjust to going back to just
working on spacecraft yeah it's a really
interesting paradigm shift for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe your purpose on this planet
this planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as some of those plants started
to shut down we have to slow down
because of illnesses of workers in those
plants we were able to produce as much
meat as we're accustomed to we're down
about 40 percent of our processing
compared to the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
archeology toss another Yahoo look
there's aa minor contributor to the
sinkhole
hang on one second people that are doing
a song see you Monday - take this money
- we're sorry tengo que vio algo para
she Manzo - who minima
hinden buzzer you did she wore for those
who don't know where she's a cross
between Martha Stewart and Kim
Kardashian we're here today at the front
of the dome from oil factory where Waya
who hosts an hours-long fundraiser for
Han struggling businesses back on April
1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars
Tommy this is 40 million people in China
are watching his life's in the show I
seen herself and takes everything from
nothing active crayfish life is slowly
returning back to normal Rohan right
across the street from the pawn on
seafood market we were told by the
police not to take any photos in front
of the market we heard today that allow
the sellers will be
[Music]
[Music]
no more deities are beefed up a lot of
orders just kid taking like instantly in
less than 10 seconds you got to be quick
instead of me just being stuck inside
the house and be able to do something
productive and make money while doing it
signed up around wink Ovid really
started going people would just be
ordering things around out of stock
[Music]
I'll go to an area that I think is
pretty busy or I know is pretty busy
from past experience and I just sit
there on the app and just refresh it
about two to three days a week
the in cigar game is pretty competitive
sometimes I'll work really hard on huge
order and I'll be kind of upset that you
know just just not getting any tips in
the little fee that they that they're
charged from instacart
wearing a face mask at all times
I keep hand sanitizer on me I also
sanitize my car because I'm always
bringing stuff inside my car as well
I did strike gold on one big order got
about a $500 order it's not always like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a g40 single argument with andhakasura
okay to the future China's international
magazine Shiva Camuto Sando okay a
Bushman amiable Coliseum with the local
populace it was own characters attending
a lot of animosity towards Allah Allah
Allah soup okay no chopper a Givenchy
Sol antenna porque si tu vas a ser para
la jinn to Ventura's entre la necesidad
de una vida inteligente a homage Trisha
for Mancala a familiar name it is a
subliminal image follow a physical pooja
my sage remain to you know pass
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have become
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now the spacecraft you know
once we launch it and it's out in space
if something goes wrong you know nobody
can go up there and fix that that one
little thing and so in that regard we're
used to happy to you know very very
meticulously analyze any potential fault
scenario that we could encounter for us
8th craft and for a medical device you
know we we took that same exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next level I think
a lot of us really don't know how it's
going to be to adjust to going back to
just working on spacecraft yeah it's a
really interesting paradigm shift for
sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe your purpose on this planet
this planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as so those plants started to
shut down we have to slow down because
of illnesses of workers in those plants
we were able to produce as much meat as
we're accustomed to we're down about 40
percent of our processing compared to
the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ocular to toss another Yahoo Lopez or
America's hundred other to receive oh
whatever
and it 21 people that are doing a song
see you Monday - take this money - we're
sorry
tengo que vio algo para she Manzo -
Adama
hinden buzzer you did she wore for those
who don't know where she's a cross
between Martha Stewart and Kim
Kardashian we're here today at the front
of the dome from oil factory where Waya
will host an hours-long fundraiser for
Han struggling businesses back on April
1st
she actually sold a rocket for 40
million yen which is roughly about six
million dollars sama the season 40
million people in China are watching his
life's in the show I seen herself and
takes everything from ducking active
crayfish life is slowly returning back
to normal Rohan right across the street
from the fawn on seafood market we were
told by the police
not to take any photos in front of the
market we heard today that allow the
sellers will be
[Music]
[Music]
a woman shouldn't tease our beef up a
lot of orders just kid taking like
instantly in less than 10 seconds she
ought to be quick instead of me just
being stuck inside the house and be able
to do something productive and make
money while doing it signed up around
wink Ovid really started going people
would just be ordering things around out
of stock
[Music]
I'll go to an area that I think is
pretty busy or I know is pretty busy
from past experience and I just sit
there on the app and just refresh it
about two to three days a week the insta
guard game is pretty competitive
sometimes I'll work really hard a huge
order and I'll be kind of upset that you
know just just not getting any tips in
the little fee that's it that they're
charged from instacart wearing a face
mask at all times
I keep hand sanitizer on me I also
sanitize my car cuz I'm always reading
stuff inside my car as well
I did strike gold on one big order got
about a $500 order it's not always like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Yashiro okay to defeat encourage
international magazine Chiquita moon to
preach today okay yushkin America resume
with a robot hi Bella citizen quwata
illa Allah Muhammad also avocado soup
Okinawa parade eventual Super Nintendo
porque si T vs alpha religion Juventus
on trial a necessity acts of the you
know mythology intelligence of the
homage trick for you much colder for a
familiar name it is a subliminal image
follow you physical pooja my sage
through mental you know boss
[Music]
all right so this is our first prototype
circuit what we did was this mantel a
leaf blower to find a three-phase
brushless DC motor with a blower and a
housing already ready to go it kind of
turned into you know instead of thinking
hey how can we do something with what we
might find in our garage it was a
merging of all of the flight practices
and processes that we have become
accustomed to going through for
developing a flight project kind of
combined with well this has to happen
like right now the spacecraft you know
once we launch it and it's out in space
if something goes wrong you know nobody
can go up there and fix that at one
little thing and so in that regard we're
used to having to you know very very
meticulously analyze any potential fault
scenario that we could encounter for us
ace craft and for a medical device you
know we we took that same exact approach
[Music]
it's just been really next level a lot
of us really don't know how it's going
to be to adjust to going back to just
working on spacecraft yeah it's a really
interesting paradigm shift for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be your purpose on this planet
this planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as soon as so those plants started to
shut down we have to slow down because
of illnesses of workers in those plants
we weren't able to produce as much meat
as we're accustomed to we're down about
40 percent of our processing compared to
the same time last year
[Music]
[Music]
and they said oh you wouldn't have any
problem that's what they were trying to
do and it's a disgrace the Obama
administration Justice Department was a
disgrace and they got caught they got
caught very dishonest people but much
more than two cents treason it's treason
so I'm very happy for General Flint he
was a a great warrior and he still is a
great warrior now in my book he's an
even greater warrior what happened to
him should never happen again and what
happened to this presidency to go
through all of that and still do more
than any president has ever done in the
first three years is pretty amazing when
you think of it with what we've done
with regulations and tax cuts and Second
Amendment and all of the things we've
done it's never happened and until two
months ago we had the greatest economy
in history unfortunately we had a like
you did in Texas we had to close it down
but for these people to have done that I
am very proud of General Flint I can
tell you that right now oh the people
should pay a big price for what they've
done to this country they should pay a
big price and their partner very
complicit is the thing called the media
the media is totally guilty and all of
those writers and so-called journalists
in are journalists they're thieves
all of those journalists that received a
Pulitzer Prize should be forced to give
those Pulitzer Prizes back because they
were all wrong there was no because if
you saw today more documents came out
saying there was absolutely no collusion
with Russia came out very loud and clear
and they were out for years because they
tried to do a number on the presidency
and this president happened to be me
Pulitzer Prizes should all be returned
because you know what they were given
out falsely it was fake news they're all
fake news those Pulitzer Prizes should
be given back immediately and the
Pulitzer committee or whoever gives the
prizes they're a disgrace unless they
take those prizes back because they got
Pulitzer Prizes for what turned out to
be false stories and Pulitzer Prizes
should be given to the ones that got it
right and I could give you a long list
of those names too and you know who I'm
talking about I did yes we we are
helping various countries as you know
Russia's having a hard time with the
same kovat 19 they got hit like
everybody else got hit and we had a long
talk and also the 75th year and you know
what the 75th year means it was very
nice he called me because we were
partners so to speak for a very big
successful war and it was very nice he
called too as a congratulatory call it
is a call of celebration because it was
the 75th year and also I suggested if
they need because we have a lot of
ventilators if they need ventilators
we'd love to send them some and we will
do that at the appropriate time we'll
send them some ventilators yeah we'll be
doing that and no it's a very nice girl
and remember this the Russia hoax made
it very hard for Russia and the United
States to deal with each other they are
a very important nation we're the most
powerful nation they're a very powerful
nation why would we not be dealing with
each other but the Russia hoax is
absolute dishonest hoax made it very
difficult for our nation and their
nation to deal and we discussed that I
said you know it's a very appropriate
time because things are falling out now
and coming in line showing what a hoax
this whole investigation was it was a
total disgrace and I wouldn't be
surprised if you see a lot of things
happen over the next number of weeks
this is just one piece of a very
a dishonest puzzle we are talking about
arms control with Russia and we will go
forward with that and we are talking
about a verse seriously having arms
control they have many nuclear weapons
and so do we
and we're talking about a arms control
with Russia yeah they'd like to do it
we'd like to do it well yeah Peter the
number will start coming down at an
appropriate time what whatever that is
well I I'm viewing the third quarter as
being a very important quarter because
it's as I said that'll be a transition I
think you could almost say a transition
into greatness because I think next year
we're gonna have a phenomenal year a
phenomenal year economically and we're
working very hard now are the governor's
working along with us the relationship
with Texas has been phenomenal and Texas
is opening up in a lot of places are
opening up and we want to do it and I'm
not sure that we even have a choice I
think we have to do it you know we this
country can't stay closed and lock down
for years somebody could say let's keep
it closed for a couple of years the
United States of America the greatest
economy in history two months ago in the
history of our country
in the history of the world we had a far
greater economy than anybody including
China by a lot and we had to close it
down in order to really do something
about the plague but we did something
and we did a lot and we also you know
what governor we learned a lot about it
we know that you may have fires every
once in a while at certain locations
some little ones maybe some big ones but
you know how to shut it down sure I was
talking with dr. Burks about that and so
what we've done we've been able to
contain the spread of the corona virus
in Texas but at the same time we created
these surge forces that will go out to
regions where there are flare-ups
it's like putting out a fire now we have
a sir
working in the Panhandle in Texas right
now up in Amarillo just north of
Amarillo because of an outbreak at a
meatpacking plant there's several other
issues with other packing plants in
Texas
basically there's only three categories
causing any type of outbreak there are
meatpacking plants that there are jails
and there are senior centers and so we
have task forces that focus on those
three areas if it weren't for those
three categories the people in Texas
testing positive would be very minimal
and the governor and I have spoken about
what he's doing with senior citizen
centers is incredible the the time and
effort and love that you're giving to
senior citizens and they were just what
has gone on throughout the country in
some instances as you know senior
citizens areas and the governor's really
made that a point really almost before
anybody I can think of because of that
we have one of the lowest death rates in
the United States of America well
there's there's different standards used
in different communities however today I
made one thing clear and that is as we
go through this process of trying to
maintain order in our states as we are
asking the people in our state to comply
with these orders we should not be
taking these people and put them behind
bars these people who have spent their
life building up a business and being
told to shut it down and lose every
penny they have and then if they don't
follow every little you know fine point
of all the rules they certainly are
subject to arrest
that is wrong and that's why I issued
another executive order today saying
that instead of Texas no one can be put
behind bars
because they're not following an
executive order common-sense that
includes the woman that she's been
reading about was the beauty salon she's
free today good
are you there doing everything that you
can do again within the limits of
testing and you know what that is we
have the ultimate testing we're the best
tests in the world and we gave more than
somebody takes a test what's going on
there and Mike was just saying the word
essential essential workers and as you
know essential workers are immune from
that Mike do you want to make a maybe
mention that well been very clear that
from the beginning of this outbreak for
anyone that comes into contact with
someone with coronavirus we early on
recommended the people's self quarantine
that recommendation of course was before
we had done it at this point so I'm
seven point seven million tests around
the country and states like Texas are
our distributing test very quickly to
people that either have symptoms or
suspected to possibly have contracted
the corona virus but with regard to
essential workers the president referred
to we've always had an exception people
to keep food on the table people that
are involved in public safety most
especially healthcare workers we've
asked them to continue to go to work by
taking other counter measures in
including testing to ensure that they've
not contracted the disease and and as
the president indicated the White House
now is initiating an effort that the
president and I not only will be tested
every day but I think everyone that
comes into contact with the president
will be tested every day and so keeping
the essential work here at the White
House moving forward in our national
response it's the priority going forward
and the big thing is we've been tested
yes please it's great are you thumbs up
with them doing the 25% capacity for
movie theaters and restaurants and I ya
know we had a long discussion we had a
particular discussion and I think many
people know I don't understand the nail
salon piece cuz I've never had my nails
done so I understand so I didn't really
understand it so we talked about you
know not having them in the first
opening way because you can't really
physical distance and we had that
discussion and he agreed and we've moved
forward together and I think it's those
kind of dialogues and I think what's
really been impressive to me by the
governor's is how much they know about
epidemiology so they will never be
confused in another pandemic ever again
because he came with all of his data
about what County had what what that
that was a prison that was and believe
me I had all my data with me and he was
able to answer every county and what the
issue was and I think when you look at
Houston when you look at Dallas and you
see the ability to really contain and
and mitigate those epidemics but at the
same time contain epidemics and then not
allow them to spread in the community
this is what we've been asking
governor's to do with the test and using
focus testing to really find
asymptomatic cases and protect the
vulnerable and the ability to go into
prison to go into meatpacking plants and
go into the senior care centers and
proactively test it's really quite
extraordinary and I think we still
remain concerned about a symptomatic
spread and we think that the progress
that they're making on testing and a
focus way to protect others is really a
way that we can move forward together to
protect everyone in the community so
Texas is a role model for other states
every state is different so I don't want
to get in a comparison with the
governor's because I've talked to some
incredible governors who do all doing
quite a good job it's true 20 states
to multiple organizations right now that
haven't met the guidelines that you said
here have partially or completely
readable what you say to those states
that have met the guidelines that are
already starting that process now we've
looked at all of them but we've spoken
to many of the governor's most of the
governor's as you know we give leeway to
the governor's and these are governors
that have done a good job in I think all
cases I have some that I don't think of
doing a particularly good job but for
the most part they have and these
governors have and we give them the
leeway they have to do what they're
doing like Governor Abbott when you look
at the job he's done in Texas I rely on
his judgment and you have parts of Texas
vast parts of Texas where there's no
problem whatsoever I mean it's like
literally nothing and it would be a
shame to keep that closed I mean half of
our counties either have no cases or
five or fewer cases so the governors
have great have great power as to that
given by us we want them to do that we
rely on them we trust them and hopefully
they're making the right decisions so
I'm getting a full report this evening
my heart goes out to the parents and to
the loved ones of the young gentleman
it's a very sad thing but I will be
given a full report this evening No
well I don't want to talk about it but
we're doing some things we'll make it a
lot of moves in the Middle East and
elsewhere we're doing a lot of things
all over the world militarily we've been
taking advantage of all over the world
our military and in the sense that we're
and this is nothing to do with Saudi
Arabia this has to do with other
countries frankly much more we have the
most powerful military in the world
we've spent 1.5 trillion dollars since
I've been here more than that 1.5
trillion dollars on a military that we
now have the strongest military we've
ever had we have the best equipment the
best missiles planes the best of
everything
we're Otter izing and just authorized
ships new ships being built they're all
being built in the United States and
they're beauties is we have the best
submarines in the world by far and we
have submarines being built and we go
around and protect other countries and
other countries don't respect us like
they should in some cases they don't
even like us and those days are over
those days are over so things are moving
and I'm not putting Sony on that thing
but we are doing certain things that
will be positive for us and I think very
positive for them too Saudi Arabia's a
very wealthy country and they've agreed
to help defray some of the costs which
nobody else would ever ask for of course
you probably have to have a good
business person in charge of a country B
you know I don't want to sound overly
anything I just want to tell you that
very wealthy countries we were
protecting for nothing for nothing or
very little
South Korea's agreed to pay substantial
money to us which we appreciate very
much and we asked countries to help us
we spending 1.5 trillion dollars we're
spending all of this money it costs us a
lot of money or military budgets three
times more and even four times more than
the second-largest spender of money all
right it's more than that four times
more plus and if we're going to defend
countries they should also respect us by
making a contribution I negotiate with
everything and frankly this country was
taken advantage of by friend and foe but
not any longer
yeah I don't want to talk about that
yeah but we have pulled a lot of troops
out of different places you know we were
guarding the border between Turkey and
Syria and for years and with thousands
of people there and I said wait a minute
let me ask you this Turkey Syria two big
countries they know how to guard their
border they've been fighting with each
other for years why don't we have
thousands of soldiers ultimately we've
got it down to 57 soldiers and then 27
soldiers and then they were getting a
little hostile toward each other I say
get my 27 soldiers out and that was
about a year ago and I took a lot of
heat people said oh that's terrible I
said no it's not terrible nothing's
happening on the border they've been
fighting each other for a thousand years
under different names probably a lot
longer than a thousand years I said I
don't want my troops there so we're
essentially out of Syria other than we
kept the oil we kept the oil of course
that was better the two months ago than
it is now you know keeping the oil today
is not as good as it would have been two
months ago two months ago was a wise
thing today it's like a year today I
think so I think so by the way all
prices have gone up right which is great
for your oil industry and it's great for
jobs because it's millions of jobs we
built the greatest energy country in the
world by far and prices are inching up
then I saw it 25 today jobs good for
jobs that's what we want jobs
yes go ahead Jennifer well I think you
have to have something having to do with
liability for kovat because you can't
have a restaurant and that guy is gonna
open and it's a nice business but it's
not exactly the oil business in its
prime right and somebody leaves and they
say oh I'm gonna sue them because they
caught the plague and now whether he was
guilty or not the legal fees will drive
them out of business you can't do that
so I think you're gonna probably have to
have something I would support that I
mean you go to a game and you sue the
the team owner or you go to someplace
and it would be litigation heaven and
you never know where they caught it you
never know where they catch it so we
have to have something like that
otherwise is going to be lawsuits on I
mean there already is in this country
but you'd have lawsuits all over the
place some point when they clean up and
when everybody cleans up and when this
when the plague disappears sure I mean
you want to have international travel
our airlines are going to do very well
again we save the airlines with twenty
five billion and another twenty five
billion but no you want to have
international travel but you don't want
to have it when France is having a hard
time there you know they've done another
shutdown and Spain has having a terrible
time and Italy I don't even have to tell
you about no but we want to have we want
to be open to those countries at the
appropriate time absolutely
right now Germany were very close to
Germany we have a very good relationship
with Germany Germany's done very good
they have a very low mortality rate like
we do we have a low mortality rate also
and frankly if you took New York out of
the equation we would really have a low
mortality rate but nobody I speak to a
little time we we communicate we
communicate our countries communicate
especially is no different than anybody
else I mean I watch Fox News and I watch
others and I read a lot of newspapers
and I get a lot of information from my
people I think I'm very well-versed when
it comes to not only the pandemic but
everything I mean I'm I enjoy that and I
think I have an obligation to do it so
but there's certainly a more honorable
source than some I mean some use some is
fake if you look at CNN it's fake news
if you look at M s DNC I call it m s DNC
you know what that means right
Democratic National Committee you look
at NBC NBC to me is very dishonest news
and that's why they fired Andy lack I
guess you have to ask them but Andy lack
was a hack and they fired him and they
did a big favor to the world and to this
country but now I find NBC to be very
dishonest I find which is a Comcast
division I call it Comcast with us with
an N I don't use the M I always call at
Comcast ABC I thought he gave me a very
fair interview of the other night very
good professional I've had very good
relationships with him as you know CBS
is having a hard time but they're not
getting it straight in fact last night I
read where they did a false report where
they actually got people to make it look
like it was attended you see what
happened they got people let's get some
people
because they want to make it look like
it was turmoil and they do that with
this White House all the time they don't
they love they love the word chaos when
there's no KS whatsoever they love the
word cast but what happened at CBS
yesterday was terrible well where they
got a lot of people to try and pretend
like it was a mess amount of chaos and
disorder you saw that it was terrible so
the news media in our country is a mess
but they fired and elac and that was a
good thing that's a big step forward I
hope not I don't think so I think you're
gonna have embers as I say I think
you're gonna have some fires so maybe
some fairly big fires by comparison to
what people would even think but this
gentleman is a total professional I
think we've learned a lot if you would
have said that question a number of
months ago it would have been different
the answer would have been different but
today I think we've learned a lot and
you're gonna have some areas in Texas
where you'll have to put them out and
he'll put them out what do you think
about that well we have learned so much
the past few months and we we now know
first how to go in and contain but also
we now have the resources to go in and
to contain so we're going into these
meatpacking facilities we're testing
everybody or we'll go into a jail and
we'll test everybody and we will
separate those who test positive from
those who test negative but most
importantly we go into these senior
centers because their lives are so
vulnerable and we focus on our seniors
and we focus on ways to reduce their
deaths and so we now have all these
strategies to make sure that we are able
to contain any type of outbreak and that
allows the rest of the economy of big
states like Texas to continue to go and
grow while we manage and contain the
outbreaks where they exist that we
wouldn't have known two months ago he
couldn't have given that answer the
governor couldn't have given that answer
two months ago but we've learned there's
still things we don't know about this
crazy plague this particular virus but
the answer that Greg just gave which was
so good I don't think you could have
given that and I wouldn't have known
that answer either two months ago so
we've learned a lot
mr. president even said on Sunday that
there would be a very strong report
coming out soon it's coming I don't know
that I'm gonna give it to you we're
gonna learn look it came out of China
okay whether people like to say it or
not everybody knows that I guess pretty
much I think that's pretty much know
they tried to blame Europe they were
saying he came out of Europe it came out
of China went to Europe when here went
to 184 countries probably more than that
now that was a week ago 184 countries
can you believe it and it could have
been stopped at the point it could have
been stopped right at the source and it
would have been easy to do but something
something happened something happened
either they made a terrible mistake
probably it was incompetent somebody was
stupid and they didn't do the job that
they should have done
it's too bad things could happen like
that we have to help people I was
watching the solano or she looked so
great so professional so good and she
was talking about you know her children
she has to feed her children it was
great and we can do things ministerially
through executive order or otherwise
that can help a lot of people as an
example like delays we can do delays of
various filings and yeah I could see
that happening Steve I think a thing
like that could happen
well something could happen there was
talk about something happening and we'll
see what what's going on but you know
that you know the greatest thing that
could happen if we could get our country
open again and get it going again and
have people have these great jobs again
and what we've done is we've been able
to have all these thousands and hundreds
of thousands of small businesses pay
their employees even though there was no
income coming in so they're ready to
rock and they're ready to go and if when
Texas opens at other places you're
already started the process the best
thing we can do Peter is get our country
go and get it open and get it open
safely and we'll put out those little
fires or those big fires that we have to
but we have to get our country going
well we're talking to him about the good
senators we're talking no we're talking
to him about I've been saying by
American ever since I announced I was
running for office and long before that
know what bringing a lot of companies
back we were doing that long before this
happened you know Japan is having big
plants built here we have many we have
many Japanese plants coming where
they're building their cars in the you
know I said you have to do it you have
to do it and they were doing it we have
many many companies coming back to the
United States then this head and when
this is going to continue but maybe
it'll continue even more so because
we've learned a lot you know we've
learned more than just about this
particular invisible enemy we've learned
a lot we've learned a lot about the
economics and the importance of making
things in our country like we used to
you know we used to make things here and
then all of a sudden somebody became a
great global as some great genius became
a globalist but now he's not such a
genius anymore maybe he's not even a
smart person we've got to make things in
our country
that includes medicine it includes steel
you know our steel companies we had it
very good we've made it very difficult
for steel dumping and some of the
companies were doing very well now of
course we got that way late a little bit
but we'll always help our steel
companies but we have to make our
product in this country then I've been
saying that for a long time globalists
of course that's a lot of money and a
lot of and a lot of security yeah which
one which valets you're talking about
valets are all over the place and they
are they do they are and they do they do
they wear masks you know a lot of people
in the white house wear masks and
frankly a lot of people want to wear
masks until this thing goes away but we
have a lot of people in the white house
I see it all the time where they're
wearing masks and just a little while
ago they were wearing a mask there's one
of them you're wearing a mask a little
while ago and but I noticed a lot of the
reporters aren't wearing masks thank you
very much everybody thank you I will
yeah I think it's you know at the
appropriate time I think he's a hero
it's a scam it was a scam and a hoax I
think he's a hero the general thank you
good shape they're in great shape
so really get that lovely